مساء الخير الاسعار في مصر وصلت الى
مستويات قياسيه والسؤال اللي بيطرح نفسه
هل الاسعار بشكلها الفظيع جدا الايام دي
اللي طال مختلف طبقات المجتمع باستثناء
طبعا الطبقه المحدوده جدا اللي هي ال 1%
اللي طبعا من الصعب انها تتاثر باي ارتفاع
في الاسعار هل هذه الاسعار وصلت الى كيك
وصلت الى اعلى مدى ممكن ان تصل اليه ولا
من المنتظر ان الاسعار السلع والخدمات
باشكالها المختلفه تزداد ارتفاعا وتهدد
استقرار المجتمع المصري الحقيقه انه
المؤشرات والاسباب اللي ادت الى ارتفاع
الاسعار بتؤكد او قراءتها تؤكد انه
الاسعار في مصر سوف تشهد مزيدا من
الارتفاع احنا ايه سبب ارتفاع الاسعار
الاخير في مصر عندنا مجموعه اسباب طارئه
وعندنا مجموعه م اسباب جوهريه الاسباب
الطارئه او اللي هي
يعني مش كامنه او مش اسباب كامنه في
الاقتصاد المصري عندنا ثلاث اسباب السبب
الاولاني هو بدء تطبيق قانون القيمه
المضافه كان القانون اللي موجود او قانون
الضريبه اللي كان موجود هو قانون اسمه
قانون المبيعات اعادوا تسميته مره اخرى
باسم قانون ضريبه ضريبه القانون قانون
القيمه المضافه اللي معروف في عدد كبير من
الدول خصوصا في الاتحاد الاوروبي واهم
حاجه لانه قانون معقد يعني اهم حاجه في
هذا القانون واللي يهم المواطن انه
الضريبه على اثر تطبيقه ارتفعت من
10% الى 13% العام الحالي وهتبقى 14% في
العام المقبل ده اول عامل العامل الثاني
هو اصرار الحكومه او تعهدها في برنامجها
لصندوق النقد الدولي وقبل صندوق النقد
الدولي بان هي تحرك اسعار كثير من اشكال
الطاقه اذا كانت الكهرباء او اذا كانت
الغاز والمفروض كمان ان الحكومه معلنه من
حوالي ثلاث سنين ان هي تحرك اسعار البنزين
والسولار وهي بتتلكك خوفا من رد الفعل
الغاضب جدا وكمان ساعدتها انخفاض اسعار
البترول عالميا لكن الخطوه سوف تاتي سوف
تاتي الامر الثالث او الخطوه الثالثه اللي
الحكومه ما عملتهاش حتى الان لكنها حتما
سوف تقبل على على اتخاذها وهي فكره تحريك
سعر الجنيه كلمه تحريك سعر الجنيه كلمه
شيك يعني كده او كلمه غامضه نقصد بها خفض
سعر الجنيه الثلاث عناصر دول كلهم هيكون
لهم اثر كبير جدا في رفع الاسعار في سبب
رابع ما بعتبرو طارق لكنه مرتبط بيهم
بعتبره سبب جوهري في البنيه المصريه هو
اللي انا بسميه تحالف مواطن ومخبر وحرام
يعني اذا كان الضريبه المضافه مثلا زادت
من
10% الى 13% القانون قال بغض النظر عن
المسميات ده مبيعات ولا مضافه اذا كان
القانون قال ان الضريبه الجديده
13% بيحصل نتيجه انعدام الرقابه اللي هو
المخبر
وا الجشع الكبير جدا لكثير من التجار
والمصنعين اللي هو الحرامي وعجز المواطن
اللي مضطر يتعايش مع هذا العكس فبن شوف
ايه نشوف حاجه مثلا على سبيل المثال
قيمتها زي كروت الشحن بتاع الاتصالات اذا
كان الكارت ب 10 جنيه فالمفروض انه لما
تزيد الضريبه تزيد ا بقيمتها اللي مفروضه
قيمتها اللي مفروضه دي كانت 10% يعني ال
10 جنيه ديت كانت بتتضمن الضريبه اللي هي
10% لما تزيد الضريبه هتزيد الفرق بس
الجديد اللي بيحصل ان هم بيضيفوا ك كامل
الضريبه فيبقى كانه فرد 10% قديمه و 13%
جديده بقت الضريبه بدل 13% بقت 23% انا
بقول ده مجرد مثل مش على كروت الشحن
تحديدا لانه كروت الشحن ليها تفاصيل
والادويه لها تفاصيل قصه طويله انا مش
بناقش القانون بنلاقي حتى السجاير اللي
غليت في مصر واعلن عن اسعارها الرسميه في
كل مكان في ارجاء مصر المختلفه باستثناء
عدد منافذ محدود جدا وهي السوبر ماركت
الكبيره وبعض البنزينات الران اواي
والحاجات دي اللي بتبيع بالسعر المحدد
بنجد انه في كل مكان في مصر كل تاجر وكل
كشك وكل بائع على رصيف بيخالف التسعيره
السلعه المسعره هي السجائر وبيزود جنيه او
2 جنيه وبدون اي سبب تحت سمع وبصر الجميع
وقس على ذلك فاذا كانت الاسعار ارتفعت
بفعل الضريبه المضافه وارتفعت بسعر تحريك
اسعار الطاقه في اشكال مختلفه واذا كانت
الاسعار هترت مع تحريك مع خفض اسعار
الجنيه كل ده في اخد ونظر كل ده هؤد الى
ارتفاع لكن كمان اللي بيضاعف من شعور
المواطن بارتفاع الاسعار هو الفوضه
الكامله والغياب الكامل للرقابه واللي
بتستفيد منه كل الجهات الرقابيه اللي
بتستفيد في ابتزاز التاجر ودا حريصه انه
تتركه يخالف علشان يكون دايما مصدر لسبو
وللرزق
ولرشاش الفساد وتقاعس الحكومه وغيابها
اصبح مستسلم زي ما بقول لحضرتكم في
التحالف اللي بميه تحالف المواطن او
المواطن والمخبر وحرامي زي ما قال داوود
عبد السيد المخرج العبقري في فيلم المعروف
باستثناء الثلاث اسباب دول او بالاضافه
الى الاربع اسف اسباب دول اللي انا اشرت
اليهم طبعا عندنا ارتفاع الاسعار او اصل
الداء اللي اشرنا اليه في اكثر من فيديو
قبل كده ليه اسباب جوهريه بقى في الاقتصاد
المصري ضعف انتاجيه الاقتصاد المصري ضعف
الاستثمار المباشر مافيش استثمار مباشر
مافيش سياحه تراجع الصادرات كل الاسباب
اللي احنا قلنا عليها قبل كده اللي بتادي
في النهايه الى انه
اقتصاد اقل مما يجب ان يكون لبلد فيها
اكثر من 90 مليون بتعتمد كثير جدا على
يارد وليس على التصدير وبالتالي فانت عندك
طلب لا يقابله انتاج وبالتالي الطبيعي ان
يكون في ارتفاع للاسعار لكن مش الطبيعي ان
يكون بهذا الحجم الكبير الاسعار للاسف اذا
قصنا على الفتره الماضيه سوف تزداد
ارتفاعا هذا امر من المؤكد لكن الغير مؤكد
واللي مش واضح وقدره الناس على التحمل
وقدره الحكومه على احتواء غضب الناس
واحباط
في الفتره القادمه اشكركم والى لقاء اخر
ان شاء الله